hey everyone eric voss here in the new
rockstars blue dungeon and
we just got a new trailer for matt
reeves the batman starring robert
pattinson at dc's fandom and normally
here at new rockstars we like to take a
few days to
you know slowly go through this frame by
freaking frame and find all the details
that you might have missed because
proper investigation takes time
but because it's a new freaking batman
movie and we're so damn hyped and
because you know it's the craziest year
of our lives and we are
thirsty for new things to break down
we're gonna do something unprecedented
here and just do a live reaction
to this trailer and then on monday we're
gonna do a true deep dive and find all
the little missable goodies to break
down what this movie's going to be
but without further ado let's react to
this trailer
i'm hearing duct tape i know that sound
and not for
any weird reasons some of them are weird
they're doing it they're doing it
they're doing the no more lies i knew it
i knew this is how it was gonna begin
that is is he breathing what is that
sound
oh who is that
is this nirvana friend
i see a green clue
oh this is great he's already there
world's greatest detective
oh i'm gonna be breaking down i love a
good newspaper clipping wall
did i see like weird zodiac markings
this is like this is fincher this is
like
seven stuff they talked about a crime
war like chinatown but this is more like
90s grunge
i love it oh there's her
and that's the voice of andy circus
whoa whoa what does that car say oh my
god
we got a human bomb we got a human bomb
oh my god this is our selena kyle
true cat burglar is is that colin
farrell
oh my god yeah this this feels super
fincher
[Music]
he's already dead
[ __ ] yes look at that oh my god this is
great
oh you just took a shot that is colin
brown he is
beefed up like in the way i'd be [ __ ]
oh great song choice
you're part of this too the waynes are
connected
oh man
coming out in 3031
hopefully sooner guys uh
i am floored by this trailer i it
sounded like uh matt reeves has maybe
25 to 30 of the movie shot but that
looks like they got the movie all
figured out and ready to go the the tone
the production design
you know it's weird because they did say
like um taxi driver
uh chinatown french connection was the
inspiration point maybe
those are the movies that influenced
matt reeves when he was starting as a
filmmaker but so much of this feels like
seven or zodiac you know uh kind of
david venture
dark toned uh moody crime noir stories
where
you really get into the savagery of the
killer christopher nolan definitely
started to touch on these things with uh
the dark knight in the way that the
joker
tortured his victims and used his
victims as props to
get under batman's skin but this seems
like it's taken that whole element to a
whole freaking new level
i'm shaking i am shaking at this right
now i do like how this story is like
exploring
bruce wayne batman's relationship with
gotham's finest you definitely see some
conflict coming i mean it's not just
like we're hunting down that vigilante
because he works outside of the law
but they're actually getting in like
fist fights with him in like the crime
lab
they're giving him these like looks of
suspicion as he's walking into the crime
scene i love how they're exploring that
tension and maybe the potential
corruption within the ranks of gotham's
pd
i am so eager to go through this frame
by frame because i know there are
details already in these shots and
what the riddler's clues are like i feel
like going through this trailer is going
to be its own kind of investigation as i
uh try to figure out
what each of those cryptic symbols mean
what's in all those newspaper headlines
and i just gotta say
everyone in this movie is unrecognizable
except maybe jeffrey wright i can't
believe colin farrow looks like that i
mean zoe kravitz has a mask on i get it
and so does paul danno i guess people
are unrecognized because they're wearing
masks all right fine but so far amazing
first impression i'm loving all the
choices matt reeves is making
this batman seems extremely violent i
heard some bones breaking
reminded me a lot of uh ryan gosling and
drive and not just because of the
driving
there were skulls that were caved in in
that movie now look many of you may have
seen the video that we did earlier this
week where i kind of try to predict the
plot of this movie based on everything
we knew and
weirdly this trailer seems to confirm a
lot of that but we know from this so far
is that clearly this riddler has
a personal connection to this batman or
knows something about him
and about his family which director matt
reeves said that this whole mystery is
going to shed some light on the history
of the wayne family and their connection
to the corruption of gotham so i think
that's what that whole thing means where
it's like
how am i connected to this and yes i am
loving so much about this suit this
weird emblem that looks like it could be
detachable knives which i have
constructed in past videos on this
channel
we're gonna dive into everything anyway
stay tuned we are gonna be breaking down
not just this trailer frame by frame but
we're going to go through the snyder cut
trailer because i am telling you
zack snyder hid a ton of clues in that
one that's just for people like us
to find and theorize on and of course
everything we learned at dc's fandom
what a day james gunn's suicide squad
looks amazing apparently
the flash is gonna fix everything people
didn't like about dc films for the past
20 years and that wonder woman 84
trailer perfect
i hope you also screamed at your screens
and uh confused your roommates and
neighbors
you know what you guys should be
watching this trailer too anyway be sure
to like this video subscribe to
rockstars follow me at eavos on
instagram keep an eye out for those
trailer breakdowns because we now
have things to talk about bye
[Music]
you